madame monsieur bonsoir dans l' affaire
du sang contaminé je vous le dise en
titre laurent fabius georgina dufoix
edmond hervé sont renvoyés devant la
cour de justice de la république pour
complicité d'empoisonnement au terme
d'un long feuilleton judiciaire sur
laquelle nous reviendrons dans un
instant cette décision très attendue n'a
donc pas suivi le réquisitoire du
procureur qui demandait un non-lieu
dominique verdeilhan françois granier
unis dans le même combat
le président de l'association des
hémophiles et le président de
l'association des transfusés tous deux
attendent empoisonnement non-lieu ou
homicide involontaire à 17 heures un
bref communiqué élus sur le pas de la
porte de la cour de justice et ordonné
leur renvoi devant la formation de
jugement être des trois anciens membres
du gouvernement
mise en examen pour homicides
involontaires et atteintes involontaires
à la tête et et des personnes plus de 50
tonnes amassés dans la petite salle
d'audience des documents des procès
verbaux des expertises
après quatre ans d'instruction les trois
magistrats ont choisi la solution
médiane homicide involontaire un délit
puni par deux ans d'emprisonnement les
avocats de la défense parle d'une
décision sous pression on est même allé
jusqu'à demander la récusation des trois
magistrats instructeurs qui viennent de
rendre cette décision alors qu'ils
étaient en train de délibérer
s'il ne s'agit pas là d'une pression sur
des magistrats l'ont ils sont sur le
point de prendre leurs décisions alors
les mots n'ont plus de sens on n'a pas
le courage d'affronter les victimes mais
il faut reconnaître qu'il ya des
victimes et georgina dufoix a toujours
dit ça commisération et ses sentiments
pour les victimes
donc je pense qu'on a effectivement
voulu chercher une éventuelle
culpabilité en laissant le soin à
l'accord justice de la république en sa
composition différente de prendre la
décision finale
une demi-satisfaction pour les victimes
un non-lieu aurait fermé définitivement
le volet politique du dossier
un procès est aujourd'hui possible c'est
une demi-satisfaction comme vous
mais surtout ce qui est important c'est
qu'il y aura un jugement les concours à
décortiquer ce qui s'est passé ce qui
est important en tout cas pour les
hémophiles
c'est non pas la vengeance mais savoir
dans le détail et publiquement ce qui
s'est passé au sein du gouvernement
les anciens ministres se sont donné
quelques heures de réflexion pour
décider de se pourvoir ou non en
cassation